you know just to look at a small point
you made
that you're not a quote-unquote active
researcher
do you you're swimming often
in reasonably good depth about a lot of
topics
do you sometimes want to like dive deep
at
a certain moment and say like because
you probably built up a hell of an
amazing intuition about what is and
isn't true
within these worlds do you ever want to
just dive in and see if you can discover
something new yeah
i think one of my biggest regrets from
undergrad is not having
built better relationships with the
professors i had there and i think a big
part of success and research
is that element of like mentorship and
like people giving you the kind of
scaffolded problems to carry along
for my own like goals right now i feel
like um
i'm pretty good at exposing math to
others and
like want to continue doing that for my
personal learning
i uh you're familiar with like the
hedgehog fox
dynamic i think this was um either the
ancient greeks came up with it or
it was pretended to be something drawn
from the ancient creeks that i don't
know who to
point it to but they had probably mocked
twain it is that you've got two
types of people or especially two types
of researchers there's
uh the fox that knows many different
things and then the hedgehog that knows
one thing very deeply
so like von neumann would have been a
fox he's someone who knows many
different things just
very foundational a lot of different
fields einstein would have been more of
a headshot thinking really deeply about
one particular thing
and both are very necessary for making
progress
so between those two i would definitely
see myself as like the fox
where uh i'll try to get my paws in like
a whole bunch of different things
and at the moment i just think i don't
know enough of anything to make like a
significant contribution to any of them
but i do see value in um like having a
decently deep
understanding of a wide variety of
things like most people who
uh know computer science really deeply
don't necessarily know physics very
deeply
or uh many of the aspects like different
fields in math
even let's say you have like an analytic
number theory versus an algebraic number
theory like these two things end up
being
related to very different fields like
some of them more complex analysis some
of them more like algebraic geometry
and then when you just go out so far as
to take those adjacent fields place one
you know phd student into a seminar of
another ones they don't understand what
the other one's saying at all
like you take the complex analysis
specialist inside the algebraic geometry
seminar
they're as lost as you or i would be but
i think uh going around and like trying
to have some sense of
what this big picture is certainly has
personal value for me i don't know if i
would ever make like
new contributions in those fields but i
do think i could make new like
expositional contributions where there's
kind of a notion of
uh things that are known but like
haven't been explained very well
well first of all i think most people
would agree your videos
your teaching the way you see the world
is fundamentally often new
like you're creating something new and
it almost feels like research even just
like the visualizations
uh the the multi-dimensional
visualization we'll talk about i mean
you're revealing something very
interesting
that uh yeah just feels like research
feels like science fee it feels like the
cutting edge of the very
thing of which like new ideas and new
discoveries are made of
i do think you're being a little bit
more generous than is necessarily
and i promise that's not even false
humility because i sometimes think when
i research a video i'll learn like 10
times as much as i need for the video
itself and it ends up feeling
kind of elementary um so i have a sense
of just how far away
like the stuff that i cover is from the
actual depth
i think that's natural but i think that
could also be a mathematics thing
i feel like in the machine learning
world you like two weeks in you feel
like you've
basically mastered the field in
mathematics it's like
well everything is either trivial or
impossible and it's like a shockingly
thin line between the two
where you can find something that's
totally impenetrable and then after you
get a feel for it's like oh yeah that
whole
that whole subject is actually trivial
in some way
so maybe that's what goes on every
researcher is just on the other end of
that hump and it feels like it's so far
away but one step
actually gets them there
you